once again once again we're talking
about this and we bring in cbs news
medical contributor dr david agus it's
surging right now
what what concerns you most right now
you know right now it's the fact that
you know people think this is business
as usual i start to see the mass coming
off
restaurants you know waiters don't have
the mask when i saw them
last night what's really interesting is
this is a new virus
delta variant is not like the old a
virus this can spread outdoors
it could spread remarkably easily so the
same behavior before
that you could have done and been safe
you're not safe now and people have to
realize
it's new these vois or vocs
variants of interest or concern there's
not just one of them
there are several out there what should
we be looking to
you know over a million years the human
genome changed one percent
this virus can change one percent in a
day so what happens is
as the virus infects us remember it's
not alive it goes inside our cells and
divides
and can change and a new variant can
come and so we're hearing about variants
potentially popping up at different
places of the world where the virus is
going
rampant at the present time the question
is we'll become concerned
and we only know that over time there's
no lab test to say hey i'm worried about
this one
it's saying like the delta variant went
from a couple of percent
three weeks ago now it is 84 of cases in
the united states
so that obviously is a variant of
concern and the more people that are
unvaccinated
they help spread those variants faster
and you have the ability of getting
new ones that number that we said before
49 fully vaccinated that hasn't changed
in weeks i feel like
i've been reading that for a long time
just around 50 percent
what happens when we potentially get
full
authorization for these vaccines will we
see maybe those numbers go up more and a
little less vaccine hesitancy and i
think there's a headline today in the
new york times that you know companies
are waiting for that full authorization
to start to say hey
in order to come to work you have to be
vaccinated and i think we're going to
see more of that
you're going to say if you want to get
on an airline it's okay but you have to
be vaccinated because the potential of
spread is just too great
and so the hope is that can push more
people to be vaccinated because that's
what we need and
i'm listen i'm saying this from my heart
i am scared to death of this variant
and so we all have to step up and get
that vaccine and protect each other and
there's other ways it's being pushed
though in france as you've talked about
here i mean
emmanuel macron basically said if you
want to go to a bar if you want to go to
a concert something else
you have to be vaccinated and a lot of
people signed up
a lot of people millions of people
signed up and they complained and they
argued and it created discourse
we need discourse for understanding in
this country as you and i were talking
about before
you know they're not real anti-vaxxers a
lot of people just don't understand the
facts
and you know they're waiting very
diverse group of people who are not
getting the vaccine well it isn't
that that idea of full authorization
isn't that part of it there are some
people who say but it's not fully
approved
i don't want to take this no 100 i mean
what that means that full authorization
is six months of follow-up versus three
months and you're doing that
and we have that data the data are
actually out there in the world and it
looks
great um but i want church leaders
family
leaders heads of companies everybody to
step up in their own community
and start to talk more about it we need
that discourse we can get understanding
and we can get vaccines in arms
sounds like the virus is not going
anywhere anytime soon thank you dr david
agus
so much